NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" ."
FOR A FEW OVERHEATED HOURS ON
SATURDAY A GROUP OF BOYS FROM A
CATHOLIC HIGH SCHOOL IN KENTUCKY
BECAME THE MOST HATED FIGURES IN
AMERICA, TELEVISION ANCHORS
DENOUNCE THEM AS BIGOTS,
JOURNALISTS WITH HARVARD DEGREES
CALLED THEM PRIVILEGED,
REPUBLICAN COMMENTATORS CALLED
THEM BAD CHRISTIANS, A FAMOUS
ACTOR SAID THAT THEY SHOULD BE
PUNCHED IN THE FACE.
SOME ON SOCIAL MEDIA CALLED FOR
THEM TO BE KILLED.
THEY STOOD ACCUSED OF MOCKING AN
ELDERLY VIETNAM VETERAN,
UN-AMERICAN INDIAN MAN AND DOING
IT IN THE SHADOW OF THE
LINCOLN MEMORIAL.
IT HAD NO INHERENT NEWS OF
SIGNIFICANCE, IT DIDN'T MOBILIZE
TROOPS OR REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT
BUT AS A SYMBOLIC EVENT IT'S
HARD TO REMEMBER A MOMENT MORE
GALVANIZING IN WASHINGTON AS
THEY READ THEIR TWITTER FEEDS,
THE LEADERS OF THIS COUNTRY WERE
IN RARE AND SOLEMN AGREEMENT.
THESE TEENAGE MONSTERS, THESE
REMORSELESS THUGS FROM OUR
BACKWARD PROVINCES ARE LIVING
EXAMPLES OF ALL THAT IS ROTTEN
AND IMMORAL ABOUT AMERICA, THAT
WAS THE CONCESSIONS ON SATURDAY.
SUDDENLY THE STORY EXPLODED,
POPPED LIKE AN OVERFILLED
BALLOON ANIMAL.
NEW FOOTAGE EMERGED AND IT TURNS
OUT THE BOYS NEVER ATTACKED
ANYONE.
IN FACT THEY STOOD IN PLACE AS
OTHERS APPROACHED AND HARASSED
THEM.
PEOPLE DID INDEED SCREAM RACIAL
EPITHETS BUT IT WASN'T CATHOLIC
KIDS FROM KENTUCKY, WATCH.
>> A BUNCH OF CHILD MOLESTERS!
>> LOOK AT THESE [BLEEP].
>> A BUNCH OF BABIES.
A BUNCH OF BABIES MADE OUT OF
INCEST.
>> Tucker: WHATEVER IT IS YOU
JUST SAW ON THAT TAPE IT DOES
NOT CONFIRM WHAT THEY WERE
TELLING YOU ONE SATURDAY ON
TWITTER, JUST THE OPPOSITE.
THE OFFICIAL STORY WAS A LIE,
WHO KNOWS WHAT WOULD'VE HAPPENED
IF THE TAPE YOU JUST SAW HAS
NEVER BEEN POSTED TO THE
INTERNET, THEY WOULD PROBABLY BE
LIVING UNDER ASSUMED NAMES BY
NOW.
INSTEAD THE FACTS EXONERATED
THEM AND IMPLICATED THEIR
ACCUSERS FROM BRUNCH TABLES
ACROSS WASHINGTON REPORTERS
RUSHED TO DELETE THEIR OUTRAGED
TWEETS.
SOME OF THEM EVEN APOLOGIZED FOR
PASSING RASH JUDGMENT AND GOOD
FOR THEM.
AMAZINGLY MANY OTHERS PRETENDED
AS IF NOTHING HAD HAPPENED, THEY
ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEW TAPE, THEY
KEPT UP THEIR ORIGINAL ATTACKS.
BEING WOKE MEANS NEVER HAVING TO
SAY YOU'RE SORRY, SENIOR
POLITICAL ANALYST WHISTON POWERS
NOW SAYS THE BOYS ARE GUILTY OF
DISRESPECTING AN INDIGENOUS
ELDER, THAT ELDER WOULD BE
NATHAN PHILLIPS THE MAN WITH THE
NOW FAMOUS DRUM.
THERE IS GROWING EVIDENCE THAT
HE CONCOCTED KEY ELEMENTS OF THE
STORY AS WELL AS PARTS OF HIS
OWN BIOGRAPHY AND HE'S DONE IT
BEFORE.
THE PRESS ISN'T RUSHING TO FIND
OUT, KRISTEN POWERS DOESN'T CARE
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER NOR DID SHE
SAY HOW THE BOYS DISRESPECTED
PHILLIPS.
IDENTITY POLITICS DOESN'T
CONCERN ITSELF WITH TALES LIKE
THESE COME IT'S NOT ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS OR WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED TO SPECIFIC PEOPLE ON A
GIVEN DAY.
IDENTITY POLITICS IS A SET OF
MORAL JUDGMENTS ABOUT GROUPS,
SOME GROUPS ARE ALWAYS RIGHT NO
MATTER WHAT THE TAPE SHOWS.
LAURA WEGNER DIDN'T EVEN BOTHER
TO LOOK AT THE TAPE, WAGONER IS
A REPORTER AT DEADSPIN, THAT
USED TO BE A SPORT SITE BEFORE
THE REVOLUTION BEGAN.
SHE DESCRIBED THE BOY'S BEHAVIOR
AS RACIALLY CHARGED FRENZY,
BARELY CONTAINED VIOLENCE THAT
WAS COMMITTED BY A FROTHING MASS
OF MAGA YOUTH.
SHE WENT ON LIKE THIS AND ANYONE
WHO DISAGREED WITH THE
ASSESSMENT IS A RACIST.
THERE IS LITERALLY NOTHING IN
THE RECORD THAT DOCUMENTARY
RECORD ON TAPE OR THE TESTIMONY
OF ANYONE TO SUPPORT ANY OF HER
CLAIMS.
EVERY WORD IS JUST MADE UP OUT
OF NOTHING.
IMAGINE IF SOMEONE WAS WRITING
THINGS LIKE THAT ABOUT YOUR SON.
AT COVINGTON CATHOLIC, CLASSES
WERE CANCELED TODAY THANKS TO
PEOPLE LIKE LAURA WAGNER, THERE
WERE TOO MANY THREATS.
HERE ARE TWO SENIORS FROM THE
SCHOOL.
>> SEVERAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
BLATANTLY LIED ABOUT THE EVENTS
REGARDING THE CONTROVERSY IN
D.C. AND IT HAS AFFECTED THIS AS
A COMMUNITY AND INDIVIDUALS
GREATLY.
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY THREATS
AGAINST OUR LIVES AND OUR
PARENTS, SOME OF THESE THREATS
INCLUDE THAT WE SHOULD ALL BE
LOCKED IN THE SCHOOL AND IT
SHOULD BE BURNED TO THE GROUND,
THE SCHOOL BEING BOMBED, SCHOOL
SHOOTING THREATS, I MYSELF
WASN'T EVEN PRESENT BUT I'M VERY
VOCAL ABOUT DEFENDING MY SCHOOL
AND MY PEERS AND I HAVE BEEN
DOXXED ON THREE SEPARATE
OCCASIONS.
THERE ARE REAL CONSEQUENCES FOR
THESE AND IT ALL SPEWS FROM A
32ND CLIP TAKEN OUT OF A TWO
HOUR VIDEO OUT OF CONTEXT AND
PEOPLE JUMP TO THE CONCLUSION
BEFORE THE WHOLE STORY WAS
RELEASED, NOBODY DID THEIR
RESEARCH AND ITS NOW SHOWING.
>> Tucker: YOU WOULD THINK
SOMEBODY AT SOME POINT IN MEDIA
LAND WOULD WONDER HOW ALL OF
THIS MISREPORTING IS AFFECTING
THE KIDS WHO WERE FALSELY
ACCUSED.
BUT NO, THERE IS NO SYMPATHY FOR
COVINGTON CATHOLIC IN AMERICA'S
NEWSROOMS.
IN THE MIND OF YOUR AVERAGE
REPORTER, THESE KIDS ARE A
DIFFERENT COUNTRY, LESS THAN
THAT, THEY ARE FROM A HOSTILE
COUNTRY A PLACE WE MUST SUBDUE
FOR OUR OWN SAFETY, THAT'S THE
ATTITUDE AND IT MAY ACCOUNT FOR
THE LEFT'S EMBRACE OF VIOLENT
RHETORIC IN THE AGE OF TRUMP.
BACK MORE THAN A YEAR AGO WHEN
CNN ANCHOR IS PUBLICLY DEFENDED
NT FOR, IT SEEMS LIKE AT THE
TIME THEY MIGHT HAVE MISSPOKEN
THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT NT 4.0
WAS.
NOW IT'S CLEAR THEY KNOW EXACTLY